we've been using Apple 16 inch MacBook
Pro with the brand-new 5600 I'm graphics
option for over two weeks now and the
performance has been so good that we can
confidently say that it actually makes
sense to buy this MacBook Pro right now
instead of waiting for a high-end arm
version later the main reason is that
the people who are in the market for
this high-end MacBook Pro need reliable
and fast performance and there's a very
good chance that the third-party apps
they use right now will take a couple of
years to get completely re optimized for
arm or at least to get to the same level
as these current intel-based Macs but
even discussed all of the reasons why in
yesterday's video so be sure to check it
out after this one is over so getting
back to the 5600 M 16 inch MacBook Pro
the performance has been nothing short
of incredible it is so good that this is
the first time we're seeing a MacBook
Pro mashing up to the performance of
desktop Mac's that are even more
expensive while not being portable like
the MacBook Pro is not only did we see a
massive improvement in graphics
performance so much so that it
outperforms the most popular EGP you set
up in every single test that we ran
which I'll show you in just a minute but
we even saw process of performance
improvements as well
I even compared it to my $15,000 Mac Pro
in a recent video and we concluded that
it actually makes more sense for most
people to just buy the 5600 M equipped
MacBook Pro where they would have needed
to buy that Mac Pro just six months ago
now I want to show you guys some of the
impressive results comparing this new
2020 5600 M MacBook Pro in the previous
best which was the 5500 8 gigabyte GPU
with you the same exact 2.4 gigahertz
ini and CPU and 32 gigabytes of RAM but
first I want to mention that you can
find our new Apple product merch right
below this video in the merch shelf in
terms of RAW processing power using
Geekbench 5 the 5600 M model improved by
about 250 points and in the more
realistic cinema chart 20 stress tests
our score improved by around 6 percent
and that's impressive since it's
literally the same exact CPU and the
same exact chassis we even exported 542
megapixel RAW images in Lightroom and
the new model finished 3 minutes faster
that basically shows us that the 50
600m graphics model somehow has better
cooling for the processor itself
allowing it to clock higher and perform
better but that's not the main focus of
this new machine the major difference is
the graphics in terms of raw graphics
performance the 5600 M was 50% faster
than the 5500 M which was the previous
best graphics option and that's with
having the same exact 50 watt TDP into
our surprise we saw an even bigger
difference running Unigine heavens
gaming benchmark in Windows 10 using
bootcamp how could this be possible with
the same TVP that is optimization the
5600 has the more optimized Navi 12
graphics chip and while the clock speeds
have been dropped we have 40 graphics
cores instead of 24 which is how they
are getting this amount of performance
per watt naturally we had to test gaming
performance and for at night and Call of
Duty warzone and we found that we could
get a consistent 60 fps or higher with
fairly high settings and that was with
the default bootcamp drivers which
actually were just updated so it's
probably even better performance now
this puts the 5600 M in line with the RT
X 2060 in terms of performance all while
having much faster memory and using
quite a bit less power as well which is
why the 5600 M is really impressive
we've tested multiple laptops with 2060
graphics cards and while most of them
cost quite a bit less money while
offering similar performance there is a
massive drop-off in performance when you
unplug the laptop on top of that they
all require big power bricks and can't
be run off of us PC power this is where
the 5600 M really shines you get that
same performance one on the go all while
getting way better battery life about
double and you can run off of a cheap
USB type-c power bank do the whole
laptop using less than 100 watts of
power because of this if you need the
best graphics power while on the go the
5600 M equipped MacBook will even beat
out the most powerful windows laptops
like the Quadro equipped blade studio
while costing less and having a faster
CPU it doesn't stop there we
compared the performance of this 5600 a
MacBook Pro to our 5700 EE GPU and this
thing by itself got much better PS which
I wasn't expecting and all of that power
is built-in you don't have to deal with
an e GPU and if you watch that video
from a couple days ago you'll know that
each GPUs can actually slow down
performance for things like video
editing now here is the crazy part in
terms of gaming we tested the best Vega
48 graphics card in the 5k iMac and it
only scored 75 point for fps under Union
heaven in bootcamp compared to this
laptops eighty three point eight so we
can now confirm that the 5600 mm 16 inch
MacBook Pro is by far the best value
option for anybody who wants to play
games in Windows 10 using bootcamp being
a much better choice compared to buying
any GPU or buying an expensive high-end
Mac desktop now one of the concerns that
I've read is that the 5600 M will
overheat and lose performance during
long workloads like gaming but when we
filmed our gaming review we played for
many hours under boot camp and the
performance was consistent this shows us
that the cooling system was keeping up
just fine
a lot of people also asked us about the
fan noise well connected to an external
display and I can confirm that this
issue is now fixed at least with a 5600
M I connected it to Apple's 6k Pro
display XDR and the MacBook Pro was
staying cool and completely silent this
is a multi-part issue with the previous
MacBook so if you want to know more
watch our how to fix your 16 inch
MacBook Pro video now is such on
productivity where this new 5600 a model
continues to impress us we ran a version
of the blender benchmark which uses
graphics and it was 30% faster than the
5500 M model in our Blackmagic raw 6k
export test using DaVinci Resolve the
5600 M was an even bigger 60 percent
faster and we see a really good
improvement in Premiere Pro as well
finishing much quicker and then moving
on to Final Cut Pro X video editing
let's also introduced the 5700 x te GPU
and compare the scores in the 5k Bruce X
benchmark the 5600 M wipe the floor with
the 5500 M
the GPU was surprisingly slow and I
think that's because of a GPU
optimization issues and the latest
version of Mac OS and that's one of the
things that you have to worry about with
any GPU moving on to our one minute heb
see stabilization test the 5600 almost
twice as fast as the GPU and 50% faster
than the 5500 M and we saw an even
bigger difference in our 32nd c200 draw
stabilization with this MacBook Pro
finishing in only 39 seconds so this
basically shows how it not only beats
the GPU in gaming but in video editing
as well now there are some video editing
tasks that we ran where there was no
difference at all between the 5500 and
the 5600 and that's because the test
wasn't being limited by graphics but
actually by the maximum speed of the
hardware encoding so if you're not
pushing the graphics card hard having a
faster one won't help the only downside
of the 5600 M graphics card option that
we can find is that it's $600 more
expensive than the 8 gigabyte 5500 M
option that is a big difference in price
mostly due to the ultra fast but very
expensive HBM to memory with that said
if you're already spending over $3,000
and you need graphics performance paying
the extra price is a better value than
buying an e GPU and the power is always
there and unlike Windows laptops you can
use that power when you're unplugged as
well and I'm even gonna take it one step
further I'll say that if you're gonna
buy just one more Intel based Mac for
app compatibility and for using bootcamp
before you switch to one of the future
our Mac's the 5600 M 60 inch macro Pro
is probably the math that you should buy
hopefully you guys enjoyed this review
if he did tap that like button down
below and click the circle above to
subscribe thank you guys for watching
check out our merch down below as well
to help support the channel this man Max
and I will see you in the next video
[Music]